[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on computer system
validation your path to documenting data
integrity by eileen lisette santos i am
abby pell of lab roots and i will be
moderating today's
before we begin i would like to
encourage you to engage with us you can
submit as many questions as you want at
any time you want during the
presentation
simply type them into the ask question
box on the left and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we can
and we have time for it at the end of
the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing a presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right or
use the ask a question box on the left
it is my great honor to please welcome
eileen
thank you abby
welcome to the thermo fisher scientific
webinar on computer system validation
i am eileen bizet santos from the
professional services team representing
thermo fisher scientific life sciences
division
on this webinar i'll be sharing the
importance of computer system validation
and how it supports compliance and the
considerations on what needs to be
developed and executed to validate
computerized systems
also i will be providing an overview of
the total validation process our
consulting services and the components
used to document a full csv
in a quality system
validation is paramount as it is the
process of establishing documented
evidence to demonstrate with high degree
of assurance that systems processes
workflows and all parts within the scope
will consistently function correctly
according to specifications
when the system is carried out for
actual and routine activities like for
example testing and production
validation efforts encompass all parts
of the system so for hardware there's iq
oq and performance verification for
software there's computer system
validation
and the methods are validated by
performing analytical validation
laboratories that follow current
guidance protocols such as gxp and gam5
are good automated manufacturing
practices
require validation of computer systems
according to
21 cfr part 11 by usfda
and annex 11 for data integrity of
electronic data records
so as described in fba's 21 cfr part 11
and eu's annex 11
the validation of computer systems is to
ensure
accuracy reliability
consistent intended performance of data
records and the ability to discern
invalid or authored records as a
critical requirement of electronic
records compliance
the computer system validation or csv
service that thermo fisher scientific
provides
covers the requirement to help you
comply with regulations and industry
standards
we deliver comprehensive validation
consulting from end to end
thorough testing and documentation of
data security audit and e-signature or
what we call the sae functionalities
so to get into more details of what csv
is and what it requires
csv confirms and documents that a
computer system fulfills a set of
defined system requirements
it focuses on user requirements or how
or how the user intends to utilize the
software with emphasis on the sae
features
the verification of conformity is
achieved by comparing actual system
performance to predetermined
requirements by executing test
procedures and collecting objective
evidences in the form of like screen
captures printed reports and data files
and csv importantly it validates that
the system can identify altered or
invalid records
so when should csv be performed
definitely at installation after the
qualification of the instrument hardware
by performing iqoq and ipv
mention the software such as the
software upgrade
after a repair or replacement of the
computer hardware
and when migrating to new systems or
processes
transferring a system from rnb to a
preclinical environment or to production
so actually the decision to execute the
csv or to revalidate at its extent
should be based on risk assessment
depending on
the nature and the implications of the
changes
on this slide i'd like to share with you
how thermal pressure scientific could
help you save time and money and help
you reduce your compliance risk
so time cost and compliance are three
major factors that a company considers
critical in their operations
first about time
being fast is key to be at the forefront
as soon as your clients raise the knees
from your lab
and with several priorities there are to
struggle within a limited span of time
it is challenging keeping the balance to
establish your data integrity strategy
quickly
while adhering to the most current and
relevant guideline and at the same time
keeping the lab profitable
on the aspect of cause
establishing an effective validation
strategy requires huge resource
allocation
to develop a validation planning
methodology
also to conduct training of your staff
to implement and execute the plan and to
document the validation results
and having limited resources to cover
the full validation scope can be risky
and in terms of compliance we know that
all labs face the pressure of meeting
compliance requirements considering that
standards are dynamic meaning they get
updated from time to time and changes
are usually broad and non-specific
making it difficult to quickly apply
them in the lab workflows
so having mentioned those hurdles here
is how we could help you
we provide this ability into the full
csv process that's from planning
document review execution of the tests
review of results of the closing of the
project to ensure that your requirements
both from a compliance standpoint and
transition to production are
successfully met
we also provide integrated support
so dedicated project managers who are
highly experienced will work directly
with you to guide your csb process
and then a csv specialist will conduct a
test and provide full support during the
on-site execution
and also as the system manufacturer we
can provide end-to-end support and
solutions
in terms of flexibility for every
engagement we provide an initial
consultation to assess your specific
requirements and ensure you receive the
optimal solution that's taking into
consideration compliance with regulatory
and international validation standards
and technical acumen we have a track
record of successfully completing
hundreds of csv consulting engagements
globally
where we have constantly worked together
with
our stakeholders such as our r d and qa
departments to ensure that technical
queries and requirements are addressed
accurately
when you purchase a csv consulting
service we will lies with you to kick
off the project
and as a prerequisite of csv execution
the instrument must be installed and
qualified by our field service engineer
and then what happens is that the
project manager will then guide you
through the entire process including the
plans schedules execution and the system
release for routine use
to give you an overview of the overall
validation and consulting approach
the entire csv engagement takes about 12
weeks which is on average about 75
faster than when the labs do the
validation on their own
so once we receive the order
the first two weeks will be spent on
scheduling and holding the project
kickoff meeting by the project manager
together with the stakeholders from your
side which may include your validation
lead it qa and system owner
where we will be discussing the plan
timelines and deliverables
at the same time we will be providing an
initial questionnaire which will be the
basis of document
generation then the third week will be
the start of document generation the
pre-testing documents which are the
validation plan user requirements
specifications risk assessment and the
system configuration specification
and then the next two weeks is for the
customer to review the draft of the
pre-testing documents
where inputs and comments are provided
and we will be redrafting the documents
based on the customer feedback
week 6 to 8 is the final approval of the
pre-testing documents by the customer
and at the same time we start drafting
the testing documents which are
the test plan iq oq and pq protocols
and then the review and approval cycle
continue like the pre-testing document
where the customer will be provided two
weeks to review and approve the
documents
simultaneously on the 10th week
we will be creating the draft of the
pre-testing documents which are the 21
cfr part 11 assessment and traceability
matrix
and then once the testing documents are
approved a certified csv specialist will
be on site for the execution of the
approved protocols
and then a validation summary report
will be furnished after the completion
of all the on-site validation activities
week 12 is the closing of the validation
project when the post testing documents
are approved
and as the deliverables are completed at
this point project sign off takes place
as you can see from the timeline
majority of the activities
those that are
marked in blue are completed remotely as
this involves documentation tasks and
one week is spent on site for the
execution
so this timeline really depends on the
level of customer feedback and the
turnaround time as we move the documents
from creation to review and to approval
having a trusted partner to cover the
csp processes lessens the burden on the
organization's resources and avoids
redirecting the focus of the different
members of the departments
so typically an organization has a qa
department which supports the larger
business processes and not really focus
on a specific system or workflow
and then there's the lab on the other
hand which focuses on operations over
validation and quality management
requirements
and of course there are third-party
consultants who may fill the gap but you
also have to consider that their
knowledge on the instrument software and
sae features
may not be that extensive for them to
completely support a csv
so the clear advantage of using the csv
service boils down to having a complete
validation report
so that's having a dedicated project
manager focusing on the project from
start to finish
having an experienced validation
specialist who understands the industry
accepted approach and validation
processes
who has the knowledge on the software's
sae features
functionalities and workflow
and who executes the test cases and
documents the results in an industry
accepted format
another important support that we
provide is having the flexibility to
accommodate some of your requirements
and validation policies into the
documentation
templates
so our csv covers all that you need in
about 10 to 12 weeks for a reasonable
and low price
just as a reference here is an example
of a calculation made for an internal
csv effort
considering the average lab resources
allocated for validation
and labor rates in u.s dollars and also
considering that a csv can take from
four to 12 months when the labs do the
validation on their own or if they
choose to engage other consultants
so let's say for a validation team of
four
including specialists for computer
assistance and quality
a lab manager and a project manager
the cost could range from about 96 to
192 grand for a six month project
and 192 to 384 grand for 12 months which
is really a high investment for the
company
as you would have noted by now huge
amount of time is invested on
documentation for any csv
as a ruling validations if it's not
documented it didn't happen
csv consulting services include
comprehensive documentation
as a tangible evidence that all software
features within the sae scope are
suitable for intended use
a full csv has 12 components as per
industry standard and this 12 documents
are mapped to the gam5 validation
lifecycle
or configurable software
so it's just to briefly describe the
different documents so we start with a
validation plan which is a high level
document
that is essential to the success of the
validation
it defines the validation scope and key
deliverables
and then we have the validation risk
assessment which documents
identified operation risk of the test of
the system
impacts and prescribed mitigations
according to gaslight guidelines
then of course there is the user
requirement specification which states
the system requirements
and then the system configuration
specification which describes the
intended configuration
including um system architecture
security and data processing as some of
the examples
and then of course we have a test plan
which describes all tests identified for
the user requirements and this
plan supplements the validation plan
with details for test execution
prerequisites collection of objective
evidences and documentation
and then we have the iqoq pq protocols
which are the three phases of testing
that involve the execution of tests
using specific instruction
results and acceptance criteria and the
execution of the test cases is highly
supported with objective evidences which
will be attached together with the
protocol
also we provide a traceability matrix
which confirms that each user
requirement has been tested and
documented in accordance with the
validation plan
and then the tenth document is the 21cfr
part 11 or annex 11 or game 5 assessment
whichever is
applicable to your regions and your
regulations
it contains a checklist that maps the
guidelines and how these are met either
by technical controls true testing as
covered in the iqoqpq
or procedural control by having relevant
sops in place
in addition we have a quality assurance
review it's a supplementary document in
a checklist form which can be used by
your qa department to review and ensure
that the validation steps and objectives
have been met and the deliverables are
complete
and lastly we have a validation summary
report which is the executive summary of
the validation results
and this doc this document is often the
starting point for regulatory auditors
to gauge
how the validation was um was carried
out
we have developed our csv plans with
different levels of service and
documentation included that would best
fit your needs so in that way you can
invest in the service that caters to
your specific requirements and budget
so with the package for here which is
the complete package you get the full
service
so that includes project management from
end to end the full documentation set
full validation support and on-site
execution just exactly as i described
earlier
and then the first package is the
minimum package which is the base it
includes three documents
installation qualification operational
qualification and system configuration
specification
so this documents are provided without
customization meaning the documents are
in standard format and we provide
limited project management support
including a one-time consultation and
remote support and execution of the test
protocols is not included
the second package is plus which is a
level higher than base
as you will receive two additional
documents so that would be a risk
assessment and user requirement
specification
in addition to scs iq and oq
so this package comes with consultation
for the five documents and similar to
base the package does not come with
document customization and on-site
execution
there is also an option the premium
package with which provides the full
documentation suite but with limited
support in terms of document
customization and project management so
it's only limited to repo remote support
without execution
so in case in case of additional
services and support that you may
require for the different csv plans we
have add-on services like execution
add-on and in case you need additional
documents we have document add-on
offering that you can purchase with a
csv plan of your choice
please take note however that for our
bio production systems which are the
microseek identification and accusing
systems
we only offer the complete solution
because
this are deployed in highly regulated
environments where a full csv is
required to comply with gmp and 21cfr
part 11 requirements
the value of the csv consulting service
is directly proportional to the coverage
and services included
as you can see as the value of the csv
consulting service increases your risk
potentially decreases and the
opportunity for compliance potentially
improves so choosing the right csv plan
really depends on your available
resources
experience and expertise on csv and it
is very important
to balance compliance needs with risk
management
all right i think this is my last slide
so as a summary
validation of the computer system is an
integral part of the full validation
process
adopting the best industry practices and
investing in validation efforts place
the organization in a better position
towards
higher productivity
faster turnaround time to production and
testing and higher confidence on
compliance
and partnering with turmoil feature
scientific for your csv needs saves you
time
costs and assess you and compliance as
we provide
first dedicated project manager to guide
you on the entire validation process
a csv specialist on site to do the
execution of the iqoq and pq protocols
you will receive a comprehensive and
complete set of documents
we accommodate some of your specific
validation information to be included
into the documents
and a full validation support is
provided while the csv is ongoing from
the kickoff to project completion
for further information about
thermo-fisher scientific csv consulting
services
please visit our webpage or if you have
any questions please contact us by email
so on behalf of the professional
services team of the life sciences
division of thermal fischer scientific i
would like to thank you all for
attending this computer system
validation
webinar thank you eileen for a very
informative presentation
we did receive some questions um already
and i would like to start with the first
question
is
csv a one-time effort
right so
actually if there are no changes made
within the system the csv it remains
valid and the system is considered to be
in a validated state so csv has to be
redone in events like a major software
upgrade
repair of the computer or replacement of
the hardware as some of the examples
and the extent of revalidation really
depends on the type of change and the
effects the changes have on the system
great okay and
what is the difference between software
qualification and csv
that's a good question
um software qualification focuses only
on testing to demonstrate that the
software meets specified or standard
requirements well csv has a broader
scope as it ensures conformance to user
needs and intended use
so the testing and documentation are
more extensive and comprehensive for csv
thank you eileen and we have time for a
few more questions here
the third question is
are the 12 documents required to comply
with the csv requirements
right so the 12 documents that i
mentioned earlier are industry accepted
for complete validation based on
regulatory requirements such as
gxp
fba and europe's annex 11.
excellent
all right and we have a couple more here
the question is what takes the longest
time to develop a
csv
if we are to do it on our own
right well to come up with a complete
set of documents is already time
consuming
plus the amount of time that you need to
put in to identify the user requirements
completely and ensuring that you have
test cases built for each of the
requirements both for the technical and
the procedural aspects
thank you so much eileen and the final
question here that we're going to take
today is what are the risks related to
an incomplete execution of csv
okay so non-compliance regulations pose
a high risk so csv is actually taken
seriously by fda and by regulators and
if you happen to check the fda warning
letters there are several related to
data integrity issues
and that could have been addressed if
csd csv i mean was done correctly and
completely
thank you so much
all right well that concludes our
question portion of the presentation
today and as a reminder to our audience
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed via the email address you
provided at the time of registration
thank you again to our speaker eileen
lavette santos and to everyone who
participated in this presentation we
hope you enjoy the rest of the event
you